I'm doing the little oatmeal eyes on it
I mean what is this I'm barbecuing we
buy back win at Lakeside it for sure I
went here I want to Swit amigos join
taste leg oh there we go
[Music]
I'm tasting the damn it's the largest AB
I didn't know yeah I didn't think I was
going so it's definitely more like less
of a whisper but more like a dad like
you know I give this to Mike's only
because I'm not a sour cream kind of
girl I'm gonna give little bored I'm not
mad at these I feel like we should just
put them all on the corner yeah I'm I
had to like I'm a didn't jump back in a
nose
I'll be right in time yes my Romeo
that's the question let's really talk
about this you got all these rappers and
you chose Romeo why well nobody
recognized his face why does he say
Barbie Quinn what'd you say Levi but no
thing is like just like sweet barbecue
but I think the honey bound ate the
barbecue all right well another line you
just better than me though Joyce unlike
these I get 5 likes - I can't get Romeo
one Mike I'm sorry
Wow like his album trash like the lyrics
all right look look look look this is a
bag with character via it happen it's
spicy this is really good my tuna [ __ ]
yeah
this is a perfect - yeah ma'am they got
that nice spice to it everything about
this is right I give this 3 Mike's cuz
it was spicy and I like spicy but it is
it didn't have a when you burn I can
afford as a girl who never dry rapped
max I'm here for this I would definitely
buy them they're only a dollar I'll
definitely those again was it good yes I
thought so these ships yeah ugly ships
[ __ ] this me
[Music]